the sort of
missing story of the week is that uh
russia and ukraine might go to war or
something to that effect and it's being
cheered on by an awful lot of people who
make all the wrong decisions for the
last probably three four decades here in
the united states we've got some info
from fox news
russian president vladimir putin has the
whole world anticipating his next move
as he builds up a massive military
presence along his country's border with
ukraine with u.s officials anticipating
an imminent invasion early next year
satellite imagery obtained by fox news
on sunday highlights several locations
within western russia as well as one
location in crimea where the rush where
russian tactical battle groups
containing troops and equipment have
been deployed the plan involves
extensive movement of a hundred
battalion tactical groups with an
estimated 175 000 personnel along with
armor artillery and equipment uh jake uh
you were in the army uh well first what
do you make of uh of putin's move i
suppose but sort of secondly from an
american perspective i was watching
tucker the last couple days it's like
we're hearing a lot of people like oh
we've got to get in there and we've got
to strike russia and all this stuff and
it's like what does that have to do with
american interests with all due respect
to ukraine
yeah
for those two points first of all i
think this this russian aggression is
directly due to the weakness of joe
biden in his administration i spoke
about that during the afghanistan
debacle i think this is a direct result
of what happened in afghanistan i said
at the time it was bigger than that
withdrawal it was just the overall
incompetence uh it was clear that the
russians and the chinese were going to
test joe biden in his for in the first
year of his presidency he's being tested
he's being found wanting you know we can
uh revert these sanctions we can
reimpose these sanctions rather on the
nordstrom 2 pipeline and introduce more
economic sanctions on russia to stop
this incursion into ukraine but i think
your second point there is even more
important because look we have to
understand the history here this is not
soviet union ussr circa 1947 okay this
is not joseph stalin who is threatening
to conquer western europe okay we can be
reasonable here um you know we can
display american strength without
threatening world war three or nuclear
attacks okay you want to be
unpredictable um in your tactics and
your strategy from a military
perspective but we should not be
reckless but i think that the key point
here is to
identify the weakness of president biden
and his administration this is all due
to him we saw
american strength being projected both
domestically and internationally under
president trump i know because i served
in the army as an entry officer i
deployed to iraq under president trump
we were feared we were respected and now
we are absolutely disrespected and
dishonored yeah the point on biden's
weakness and after afghanistan is a good
one because it's like putin knows he's
got a lot of leeway right now elijah are
you amazed that uh i know your answer
unfortunately they're gonna trot out the
same people who got us into iraq the
same speechwriters the same
cast of characters who screwed
everything up with no remorse they're
going to trot them all out again and
they're going to say why we have to get
into some kind of war
yeah i think it's interesting here this
is where the establishment in the
government the neocons and of course the
war-hungry
democrats they're kind of the same thing
when you look at who they're getting
funded by and big tech you look where
their donors are
even some of them with the same
you know donors to their super pacs it's
amazing
how when we've uh inflated the economy
dave you know this we inflated the
economy our currency is down and i think
we're up for a good old war i mean
what's the cost right just uh the men
and women of our country uh young boys
young girls dying getting blown up uh
you know billions trillions possibly of
dollars of damage to the world economy
to uh property but hey you know it
serves the interest of a few people who
are powerful it doesn't do anything for
our country but you know if they want it
dave and we're only a republic right
we're only voting people in to represent
us so i mean i mean maybe one day
they'll actually actually represent us
and do something for us but i mean as
you know as a vet is on here and
realizing that these are real men this
is real women on both sides of the aisle
whether they're enemies or not we're not
we don't need another war uh you know
the pandemic's slowing down people
aren't buying the climate change bs uh
you know we're still here stuck in a
hole you know trying to get ourselves
out the supply chain and if this is
really what these global players are
trying to do god help us because this is
if biden gets us into another war
there's not a there's a lot of adult
words that i won't say on a live stream
that i would like to say to these people
and i pray to god that he spares us from
another another atrocity like this
afghanistan iraq were too much we're
finally out into an extent to them to
the severity and if this ukraine russia
thing blows over this is simply due to
incompetence if not nefarious actions
for the people that are controlling joe
biden elijah you ask too much that our
elected officials represent us i'm going
to have to make note of it i'm going to
send the strongly worded letter to
somebody over in d.c
uh matt as the as the non-american
sitting here what what role do you think
the united states is supposed to play in
these world affairs i think often i do
think sometimes i mean i don't know
about often anymore but i think
sometimes our intentions are good and
then there's always mission creeps
sometimes the intentions are not good
sometimes you've got you know speech
writers like david frum you know telling
bush to get us into iraq so that's what
we do
what what do you think the role of the
u.s should be broadly
yeah well we in europe have benefited
from american protection for 60 or 70
years and it's fantastic what's been
done to help keep the peace particularly
when the soviet union was a threat but i
think jake's right it's not about
military now
there is a dangerous uh uh world as a
result of american weakness uh and uh
it's not just ukraine uh threatened by
putin but it's taiwan threatened by uh
xi jinping it's what happened in hong
kong and the fact that we didn't respond
i think we have to find other ways of
responding to this and making it clear
to regimes like beijing and moscow that
their behavior is unacceptable without
going to war with them which would as
you have all said uh not be a productive
way of reacting
i think that's the final word on this
friday show we've all agreed to not go
to war i think that's kind of
let's not go to war you know how about
that how about we defend our own borders
rather than ukraine dave how about that
i will tell you i will take that as well